Guyane française que la sonde spartial
européenne juice a décollé en matinée à
bord d'une fusée Ariane 5 à destination
de Jupiter et c'est l'une glacée juice
se sépare la suite séparé comme prévu du
lanceur à 1500 km d'altitude un
lancement qui aura pris près d'une
vingtaine d'années à boutir au coût
astronomiques de 2,3 milliards de
dollars ça a été une énorme émotion de
voir la fusée silencée et de se dire que
d'abord il y a notre mission qui qui va
partir vers Jupiter
son arrivée dans les environs de la
planète géante est prévue en juillet
2031 avant cela la sonde survolera Vénus
en 2025 puis la terre en 2029 ce qui lui
permettra de prendre son élan vers les
lunes de Jupiter soit io Europe Ganimède
et Callisto et leur univers glacé parce
que qui dit glass dit haut et
possibilité de vie extraterrestre on va
cartographier la croûte de glace
regardez s'il y a des fissures est-ce
qu'il y a des geysers de du liquide qui
percolent vers la surface et qui sont
les chanceux va peut-être transporter
avec lui peut-être des molécules
organiques s'il y a de la vie en dessous
peut-être qu'on va non pas détecter
directement la vie mais détecter des
produits ou des sous-produits d'une
activité biologique Joe s'est ciblera
entre autres la lune Ganymède qui
abriterait un immense océan profond de
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
l'objectif sera donc d'en connaître la
composition pour déterminer si un
écosystème pourrait s'y développer du
point de vue de la strophysicien le fun
il commence en 2031 quand la sonde
arrive à Jupiter c'est là que la science
va commencer la NASA pour sa part
prépare le départ de la sonde Europa les
peurs qui devrait s'envoler vers Jupiter
l'an prochain ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal